As an opportunity
to stand back and
ask ourselves what we mean when
we talk about intelligence.
And I guess there are a couple
of reasons to think about this.
We operate now, and I call for
a moment where there are sort
of hyped up versions of what
we mean when we talk
about intelligence.
And obviously we're all here
because of one of those versions
which is, of course,
machine intelligence and AI.
And I think it's incumbent
on us to ask ourselves what
we're actually dealing with when
we're talking about machines
that operate in some realm of,
if you'd like,
artificial intelligence.
The other probably more
practical reason is, of course,
if we get the answer
to this wrong,
people won't use
the things that you build.
And there are numerous reasons,
numerous examples that we
see all over the place of
intelligence being imbedded
in various software and
hardware devices that we use and
people just switching it off.
And really that's a problem
that I feel like we face
in Microsoft and the research
people that I work in.
It's confronting AI and thinking
when will people actually want
to use something that introduces
some kind of interpretation.
And I think that's a genuine
question that we need to
ask ourselves.
So, Rebecca had
three principles.
I'm gonna talk about
three stories.
Three if you like versions if
you will of What I see to be
intelligence, or what I would go
on to talk about, capability or
capacity in practice.
And this idea of capability
is really important to me,
what I feel like we're dealing
with when we talk about
intelligence is how
the world makes us capable.
How things in the world,
how what we do in the world
enables us to be capable,
capable agents, capable actors.
And what I hope to talk about
through my three stories is how
people are being made
capable in practice.
So, my first story is about,
and obviously there
are different ways in which we
might talk about these examples.
But I wanna talk about
vision in this case.
And I'm gonna talk about some
field work that I've done with
a number of people in my group.
Around interventional radiology.
And some of you may know
interventional radiology is
a new form of radiology in
which, thanks to various things
like keyhole surgery and new
forms of instruments that allow
cameras to be placed in bodies,
surgeons can now
combine the scanning of
the body with surgery.
So prior to this, most of
the scanning would happen
pre-surgery and surgeons would
look through the imagery and
then operate on the body.
What you'll see in this video,
I think it's a two minute video,
or three minute video, is a
surgeon directing a radiologist
to continually update an x-ray.
And later on, I don't think
it's in this video, they go and
look at these MRI scans that are
on the LCD panels in the back
of the room, what I want you
to pay attention to is how
the surgeon is getting to
see the body, if you will.
How vision is, if you will,
is enacted in practice and
I'll talk through this in
a bit more detail, but
let's watch the video.
[INAUDIBLE]
in
here.
The kinds of things
that computer vision
might introduce in recognizing
scans of the body.
What is that the way in
which a surgeon starts to
understand [INAUDIBLE]
That he's involved in,
a collaboration with other
people in the surgery.
It's a very tactile thing.
Of inserting a cable
into our body, and
feeling it not with responding
the way he's expected.
So in this case what
the assistant's doing is,
he's doing an operation to fuse
two vertebrae together that
have been an injury
the patient's been subjected to.
And he's inserting a wire into
one of the vertebrae to create
a thread that he will
then tap some screws.
So then you can join
these two vertebrae
together through some screws.
But what he's finding is again
through this tactile sensation
of the wire not gripping into
the burn The burn is in fact is
soft, softer that he
would have expected.
And what they go onto do is
said to these pre ops scans and
look at the and
think, is there some suggestion
that the bone might be soft?
And it turns out that it is and
in fact,
unfortunately the patient
has a cancer But
it's only through those
activities, through the sequence
of activities and the sensation
of the wire in the bone,
through the collaboration
with these people in surgery,
through looking again at
the sequence of X-rays and
then at the pre-op scans that,
that discovery was made.
It wasn't made by looking at
the pre-ops scans by themselves.
And this is what I mean about
being made capable as it were.
The surgeon here is
being made capable
through this interactional
sequence of events.
Let me bring up that
video again Let me turn
to my second story.
And again there are many things
to kind of ponder on here in
this example but I wanted to
sort of thing about how speech
is being used because obviously
that's one of the things that we
think about with machine
learning, machine intelligence.
This is a video taken
from a workshop that two
of us attended in which we're
observing some people preparing
to teach blind children
various sports activities.
And in this case,
they're practicing an activity
that they'll do with the blind
children of throwing and
catching.
It's important to know that
Warren here on the right,
has no central vision, and
very limited peripheral vision.
And James is his guide, and
they're gonna have a go
at throwing and catching.
I should also say
that off screen,
there's another couple
throwing and catching,
and That's the noise that's
coming from outside of screen.
>> So what we're going to do
is we're going to find out how
to send And
we're going to look at different
ways that we can modify things
to make it appropriate for
the people that in your group
>> So first of all,
sending simply means making
the ball go away from you.
And receiving simply
means the ball in again.
So that could be a throw and
a catch or
it could be a kick and a stop.
It's up to you entirely.
So will you just get with your
partner and work out how you're
going to send and receive this
ball to each other [LAUGH]
>> Do you mind?
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> I can't [INAUDIBLE], but
all right.
>> I like [INAUDIBLE] week.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I've cut back in me.
I like [INAUDIBLE].
It's good, isn't it?
>> You do that.
Do that.
Try again.
>> I'm gonna try.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Sometimes here we go.
You should have that.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Try again, try again.
>> So great about-
>> Just to say that-
>> Beating him.
>> They-
>> [LAUGH]
>> Go on to do it continuously.
>> To the point where James
eventually drops the kick and
Warren catches it.
So what we might imagine to
be something that a blind
person would find incredibly
hard to accomplish turns
out to be something that they
do from the second try onwards.
Now, I've asked you to think
about the speech that's
going on there.
And I'm not sure, I mean I've
watched this video again and
again, this is sort of one of
the things I do as a sociologist
is really pay attention to
the interactional sequences that
occur in events like this.
So I'm not sure if you'll
have noticed it but,
what's happening while they're
throwing and catching.
And as they begin to throw and
catch.
And, again,
you may observe this as,
they don't just start
throwing and catching.
They just hand the ball
to each other.
They tap the ball
in preparation,
hand it to the next person.
Warren hands it to James,
James taps it,
hands it back to Warren.
So there's this building up
of a sequence of actions,
almost in preparation for
the throwing and catching.
And the talk happens
in synchrony with that
passing the ball.
And so it's as though the talk
is preparing the thrower and
the catcher for what will
then be eventually the throw.
And the catch.
I don't think that's
a coincidence.
I think a lot of work
is being done here
interactionally to
help Warren see.
Seeing here is not
a purely visual or
physiological activity,
it's an interactional one.
Seeing that Warren does
something accomplished through
the tap on the ball, through
the passing of the ball and
the sequence of interactions and
through language being sat
on top of those activities.
So when we talk about
natural language processing
it's problematic to
extricate it if you will
from the activities
that are unfolding.
And this is an area of
machine learning that I'm
deeply involved now is sort of
working with people in natural
language processing to think
more carefully about how we,
if you like ground on the data
that we have of talk.
So the last story that
I want to work through
is this is a slightly
longer video.
It's a video from a while back
in which we recorded people in
cars, just to better
understand how
domestic life extends beyond
the boundaries of the home.
Well, actually,
I'm just gonna play the video
cuz it sorta speaks for itself.
It's, I think, a three or
four minute video, so it's quite
a long one, but bear with it.
Oops.
[MUSIC]
>> Mum.
>> Yeah.
>> I wish I had a friendly dog.
>> Friendly dog.
>> Yeah, it wouldn't poo on
the carpets or anywhere, or
wee on the carpets.
>> Yeah?
>> He would find his little
cup where he did his poos and
wees in
>> No, they don't do that.
>> No, they have.
>> Cats do that.
>> They have like little trains.
That's cats, not dogs.
>> Then what do dogs do?
>> They go and poo outside.
We need to pick it
up in a plastic bag.
>> What if we did?
[MUSIC]
>> Honey, you can't even
clean out a house, not
only are you gonna manage
to clean out a dog.
>> I'm just saying, if!
>> If, yeah yeah,
that would be nice.
>> And in the nighttime
when I'm asleep,
it'll just come up and
cuddle me.
And lick me and cuddle me.
>> It'll drive you both bonkers.
That's what my dog used to do.
>> [CROSSTALK]
>> No, no,
not lick me in the morning.
>> [INAUDIBLE] in the morning
to go [INAUDIBLE] and
it'll jump all over you and
aaaah, go away.
And you put the covers over your
head like you do when I go in.
No.
No, he would cuddle
me in my sleep,
because he was really furry.
He would just go in and
out to cuddle people.
>> No, they wouldn't.
They get all excited, dogs,
when they see you, and
they lick you, and
they try and nibble your toes.
>> Yeah, but if they did.
What about
a puppy?
>> No, they'll probably
nibble and lick you.
They'll wee all over your bed,
they wee when they get excited.
>> [MUSIC]
>> Do you remember the smallest
one, he wees all the time so
he was called,
what do you call, a dalmation.
>> Please,
can I have some milk, please.
>> In a minute,
let's just get to the.
>> No, that was the one that
>> Puddle.
Is it called puddle?
>> Yeah.
He used to do wees all the time.
And he did one on a newspaper.
>> Why can't we get a dog?
>> Sorry, bit late this So what
I should have said is this is
the school run,
which you probably gathered.
And Chloe and
her mother do this every day, so
of course they know the route.
Chloe's well aware of
the geography, and
the sequence of events and
Chloe's timing here is perfect.
That last statement,
why can't we get a dog?
Is timed not to get an answer,
cuz this is a war of attrition.
>> [LAUGH]
>> This is something in which
Chloe doesn't want
the answer now.
She wants to wear
her mother down
to the point where eventually
she might just say yes.
And of course,
it starts off with if, and
ends up with why can't we?
And, if you like as an example
of someone being entirely
irresponsive to a context.
To a spatial and temporal flow
of a car moving through a city
and an organization of streets.
If you like a learning context,
Chloe is the ultimate
incarnation of
intelligence here.
But what I want to suggest is
that it's not Chloe alone,
of course.
It's that car moving
through a set of streets.
It's Chloe's recognition
of various points
along that street that
builds up this ability for
her to reach this crescendo
of why can't we get a dog.
And know that she's not gonna
get an answer for it yet.
But the intelligence there is
something that is sort of made
able through Chloe's
movements through space.
And this is what I
want us to think about
when we talk about intelligence,
is the conditions that are made
possible through a set
of interactions.
Through a set of interactions
between ourselves and
in physical and temporal space.
That we live in this sort of
fantasy of imagining that we
might go from something
like solving Go with AI to
replicating the brain.
And yet what we don't
really understand is,
what are the conditions that
we go with making possible?
Cuz they're not the same as
what we would use the brain for
in all possible contexts.
What are the very conditions
that Go enables us to do?
In fact, Go is probably one of
those few activities that we act
more like a machine than
we do like a human.
So it's not surprising,
in a way,
that AI can solve
that problem and
not solve Chloe's problem of
talking like a human in a car.
I am out of time.
I was gonna talk through
an example of how this might
be applied to natural
language processing.
So if anyone wants to talk more
about something of that context,
please come and see me later.
>> [APPLAUSE]